bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 12
avril voici les titres de ce journal se
dépister soi-même au colis de 19 le
principe des autotests dont la vente est
autorisée depuis aujourd'hui dans les
pharmacies n'était pas pour autant
disponible dès ce matin dans les
officines divine oise leur déploiement
sera progressif invités de cette édition
renault nadjani président de l'uer rhdp
est pharmacien ile de france alors que
la campagne de vaccination s'intensifier
avec l'arrivée d'un nouveau vaccin et
l'ouverture aux plus de 55 ans nous
parlerons de cette opération originale
buddy un petit robot émotionnelle est
allé au contact des personnes qui ont
reçu une injection vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sa vocation
tenir compagnie et créer un lien
rassurant et puis retour sur le
déplacement de cédric au vendredi à
bullion le secrétaire d'état chargé de
la transition numérique est venu
dévoiler dévoilé une liste celle de 339
site 4g déployés sur le territoire rural
français l'objectif en finir avec les
zones blanches 16 pylônes seront
installés dans les yvelines d'ici 2022
les détails à suivre également tout à
l'heure de cette collaboration en
matière de mobilité renault accueillera
au sein de son technocentre à guyancourt
atos thales stmicroelectronics et
dassault systèmes
le nom de cette collaboration la
software république
ils sont autorisés à la vente depuis
aujourd'hui les autotests okogie 19 sont
arrivés ou presque en pharmacie dans les
officines de montigny le bretonneux
aucun n'était disponible ce matin à la
vente la raison l'arrêté du ministère de
la santé qui a été publiée qui n'a été
publié que ce dimanche au journal
officiel
elle est précision dans ce sujet
d'eléonore sinoquet de mélanie poquet
les droit d'être vendues en pharmacie à
partir du 12
je suis pas niais qui seront présentes
en acier partir du 12
on a eu l'autorisation hier matin un
dimanche
les précommandes c'est depuis trois
semaines au moins donc là les
fournisseurs sont dans les starting
blocks va les recevoir dans la semaine
des autotests de la colle 19 qui se font
attendre dans les officines en ce
premier jour d'autorisation de vente les
clients vont donc devoir patienter
on va pouvoir leur dire prochainement ce
qu'on n'a pas encore les tests on peut
pas s'avancer maintenant à les prix on a
acquis on peut les donner donc c'est
déjà une bonne chose qu'on puisse
répondre quelque chose aux patients dès
réception de leur commande les
pharmacies vendrons ces auto test une
trentaine d'euros par lot de 5 pour le
propriétaire de la pharmacie de l'espace
saint quentin pas sûr que ses clients
adhèrent les jambes en l'air de vouloir
se précipiter pour acheter les autotests
sachant que les tests anti génie
classique sont 128 payer de leur poche
donc ils préfèrent faire les tests
antigénique classique plutôt d'acheter
les autotests qui sont vendus par cinq
aux alentours de 30 euros la boîte ayant
pour le grand public mais la sécurité
sociale pourra prendre en charge ce coup
notamment pour les personnes travaillant
avec des personnes âgées ou handicapées
s'est auto test devrait donc arriver
dans le courant de la semaine dans les
pharmacies yvelinoise et pour continuer
à parler de ces auto test renault nadja
y est avec eau par visioconférence
bonsoir bonsoir pharmaciens titulaires
d'une officine à rambouillet vous êtes
également le président du rps
pharmaciens ile de france c'est l'union
régionale et des professionnels de santé
première question vous confirmez déjà ce
qui a été dit dans le précédent
reportage même si la bande de ces auto
test est autorisé depuis aujourd'hui
en pharmacie c'est plutôt dans le
courant de la semaine que l'on pourra
vraiment s'en procurer absolument c'est
tout à fait ça alors certains chanceux
dont je fais partie ont pu s'en procurer
mais effectivement il allait y avoir en
tout cas
l'arrêté est pas fière donc c'est normal
que aujourd'hui toi tout ne va pas en
stock et d'ailleurs moi même j'étais au
g2 veut déplacer à paris pour aller
chercher quelques heures maintenant
d'autant qu'on précise qu'une partie du
stock a été réservé par le gouvernement
pour la rentrée des écoles de 26 avril
et pour celle des collégiens et lycéens
qui sera le 3 mai alors les autotests
permettront de se tester soi même à
partir de 15 ans sur le même principe
finalement que les tests pcr ont
antigénique ça se fait par un test naso
pharyngé avec un coton tige qui est à
enfoncer à l'entrée du nez très
concrètement comment ça fonctionne et et
quelle différence
à noter entre ces tests ces autos tester
les tests par exemple antigénique que
vous pratiquez en pharmacie elle connaît
d'abord c'est pas des en tout cas le
loto test ne sera pas en prélèvement
nasopharyngé là je vous présente à mener
un faux nez et je vais vous montrer ce
que c'est le prélèvement nasopharyngé
c'est à dire qu on va bien jusqu'au bout
à ses problèmes de 2,2 de la voix et
viennent par le nez juste au dessus du
plafond du pade pour toucher le
carrefour de la voie aérienne entre la
bouche et le nez alors que le test
le loto test qui nous le test que chacun
pourra faire c'est des tiges et des
échos villon un petit peu plus gros et
l'objectif c'est de mettre 4 cm mais à
l'intérieur du nez et parallèlement à la
à l'arête du nez si vous voulez d'accord
et là qu'il va falloir tourner et
essayer de ramasser le maximum de
matière le plus possible en appuyant
même peut-être sur la lune et de façon
un peu et sans aller trop loin parce
qu'on peut se blesser il ya des eaux
derrière et et faire le maximum de
prélèvement dans les deux narines donc
je fais une narine et ensuite il faut
que je fasse la deuxième n'a rien on est
bien d'accord à chaque fois on va aller
prélever à chaque fois on va tourner 10
à 15 secondes
une fois ce prélèvement ensuite on a
dans le dans le type 1
il ya un petit tube avec un petit peu de
tampon donc il faudra mettre la tige
dans le petit tube et on va tourner
pendant 10 secondes on pourra appuyer
sur le petit tube parce que le petit
tube est en plastique
on pourra bien appuyé et on tourne
pendant 10 secondes et les boîtes sont
prévues avec un petit trou de façon à
pouvoir laissait donc le le l'écouvillon
pendant une minute dans cette solution
une fois que cette partie est terminée
on pourra ensuite m le compte gouttes
qui est fourni avec dans le dans le clip
sur le petit tube et ensuite on prend
donc la petite cassette qui vous a été
cliqué dans le dans le kit aussi et on
versera 5 gouttes dans l'oeuf dans le
puits
ici c'est pendant quatre gouttes dans ce
puits et on laissera le le test sur une
surface plane de façon à des émigrés le
solvant donc le tampon de tout le long
de 2 de la plaque
en face est négatif de bien positif
c'est sa part dont un 'très est négative
de tresser positif sur sur ces
plaquettes c'est à dire que une fois que
la solution à migrer vous avez art
percée pour le contrôle pour voir que le
test a bien migrer et art pertes et pour
le test si vous avez les deux
systématiquement il faut avoir le
retrait de contrôle qui apparaît et si
vous avez le trait du test qui apparaît
donc deux traits ça veut dire que le que
le test est positif
profondément renault nadja y est ce
qu'on peut craindre aussi une explosion
des défauts qu'à négative justement est
ce qu'il ya une crainte aussi de votre
part en tant que professionnel formation
alors la crainte
évidente c'est que le prélèvement soit
mal fait et que donc le test soit un
faux dégâts tiff et donc on se croit
évidemment sans le virus ou on le dit
être sans le virus donc eu c'est vrai
aussi que le gouvernement à travailler
sur la confiance vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
des citoyens depuis le début de cette
crise et il est évident qu'il va falloir
jouer franc jeu et que si on est positif
il faut aller dans un laboratoire
d'analysés médicales fait cette fois un
trade prélèvements pcr de criblage pour
identifier le variante du virus qui est
en cause parce que l'épidémie est là
problème avec la problématique avec
cette ce virus c'est qu'il mute très
souvent et que on voit bien que les
mutants sont souvent plus pathogène que
le virus historique et toutes les tous
les outils et toutes les armes qu'on
développe aujourd'hui c'est au tour du
virus historique
donc si on ne donne pas les moyens au
gouvernement et aux services de santé
d'identifier quel est le virus qui est
en cause
on pourra pas le combat ça veut dire
aussi que les pharmaciens bon forcément
on en a déjà discuté sur ce plateau vont
avoir un rôle un rôle pédagogique aussi
vis-à-vis des clients qui vont venir
prendre ces auto test des patients qui
vont prendre ses hôtes hôtesses il faut
aussi leur expliquer comment se font les
prélèvements dans de bonnes conditions
et que c'est sans doute la raison
majeure pour laquelle a été souhaitée
notamment par le dirigeant et par les
autorités sanitaires que ce test soit
dispensé uniquement en officine de façon
à ce qu'on puisse accompagner les
patients dans l'utilisation dans la
bonne utilisation parce que ce test va
servir notamment à des personnes qui
vont être en contact régulier avec des
personnes âgées avec des personnes
fragiles avec des personnes handicapées
avec des pales sun polypathologies et
ces personnes là vont être une cible
pour le mieux et il va falloir casser
cette chaîne donc
le 30e et raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs ces personnes qui sont en
contact et qui est dont leur travail
c'est l'accompagnement social il va y
avoir une prise en charge totale de ce
test à raison de deux tests de par
semaine sur un mois donc un prix de 30
euros environ 1 pour une boîte de 5
autotests avec un déploiement progressif
on disait dans les pharmacies dès cette
semaine je voulais aborder une autre un
autre sujet avec vonona gianni alors
notre actualité du jour c'est bien sûr
la campagne de vaccination qui
s'intensifie avec deux nouveautés
l'arrivée du 4e vaccins en france
johnson & johnson ou johnsen à qui
utilise la même technologie avec thor
virale qu'astrazeneca mais une seule
dose suffit est la conséquence de
l'arrivée de ce nouveau vaccin c'est
aussi l'ouverture de la vaccination dès
aujourd'hui aux personnes de plus de 55
ans avec une semaine d'avancé finalement
sur la date prévue alors dans les
yvelines on rappelle que plus de 100 92
mille personnes ont été primés injecté
grâce à 16 centres de vaccination sur le
territoire mais aussi des médecins
généralistes et des pharmaciens puisque
renault nadja y vous pouvez administrer
le vaccin astrazeneca
comment 0 justement cette campagne dans
les yvelines est ce qu'elle va assez
vite du point de vue des les pharmaciens
est ce que les deux sont suffisantes
écoutez vous avez répondu à la question
par votre question les doses sont
insuffisants très clairement en est là
aujourd'hui dans les pharmaciens au
mieux n'ont reçu que 5 e flacons de dix
doses de ce vaccin
astrazeneca dans un premier temps et que
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'il n'y ait
que le john seine qui soit disponible et
on sait des flacons de cinq axes
donc vous voyez bien que l'on n'est pas
dans le temps l'accélération annoncé en
tout cas en tout cas pas aujourd'hui
j'espère et on annoncé qu'il y aurait
une augmentation des dotations très
importante
à partir de cette semaine la semaine
prochaine force est de constater que ce
sera une semaine de plus et donc on va
recevoir donc pour pour la semaine
prochaine
un flacon de cinq doses de john seine en
tout cas à aujourd'hui
peut-être que les choses changeront
demain et si on est personnellement j'ai
une capacité de 70 ou 80
vaccin jour vous sans perturber
l'organisation et le fonctionnement de
mon officine et je n'ai fait depuis le
début de notre autorisation c'est à dire
ça fait à peu près quatre semaines un
petit peu plus de quatre semaines que 50
max donc voyez qu'on est loin du compte
d'un côté j'ai capacités en gros 2 425
au moins 425 semaine et que en quatre
semaines je les fais que 50
yossi défiance vis-à-vis du vaccin
astrazeneca en raison des cas de
thrombose qui sont survenus comme effet
secondaire
le fait aussi que à ce jour certains
pays interdisent encore l'administration
la demie cela le l'injection pardon je
vais y arriver de ce vaccin astrazeneca
a écouté je crois qu'on fait un procès
injustifié pour ce vaccin
de toute façon il y a une réaction
immunitaire qui se met en place il y a
bon nombre de deux deux cas de co vide
malheureusement les 17,4 qu'ovide dans
un bon nombre de cas un pourcentage non
négligeable
on m'a dit alors je n'ai pas vérifié ce
chiffre mais de l'ordre de 30%
c'était dû aussi à des problèmes de
thrombose
donc on voit bien que le vaccin je
rappelle que reproduit cette agression
extérieure dans le corps et permet au
corps de de s'armer contre donc c'est
toute cette chaîne de réactions
aujourd'hui on est en train d'étudier
je crois qu'aujourd'hui eu encore une
fois c'est vrai que l'on fait parfois la
fine bouche on n'a pas le choix il faut
se faire vacciner si on veut protéger
ses proches si on veut se protéger il
faut se vacciner
c'est aujourd'hui la seule arme qui soit
à notre disposition il n'y aura pas de
la de dupes riser ou du moderna en
quantité suffisante pour tout le monde
donc il faudra bien que chacun trouve
sa source de vaccination notamment à
travers la phrase n est qu un ou une
jeune scène et encore une fois le nombre
de cas de thrombose rapporté n'a rien à
voir avec le nombre de morts causées par
l'homme par la maladie je rappelle que
en france sans la connerie il y a
environ 290 cas de thrombose
diagnostiqué par jour et que aujourd'hui
on est à cause de la kovy a plus de 300
morts par jour dira merci entre eux
entre les deux
merci renaud nadjani d'avoir été avec
nous et merci pour toutes ces précisions
je rappelle que les deux formations
rambouillet au président également de
l'ue rps pharmaciens ile de france
à propos de vaccination cette initiative
originale à présent vaccinodromes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veut dire un
petit robot doté d'une intelligence
artificielle est allé au contact et des
vaccinés au vélodrome nationale jeudi et
vendredi dernier sa vocation tenir
compagnie aux personnes et recréer du
lien notamment avec les seniors et les
enfants malades
astri bergère la rencontre et je
m'appelle béni et je suis un petit
compagnon
buddy est un robot émotionnel doté d'une
intelligence artificielle
il était au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jeudi 8 et
vendredi 9 avril
les vaccinés ont pu échanger avec lui
une occasion de découvrir ces nouvelles
technologies
j'ai pour vocation de tenir compagnie
aux gens chez eux
je peux de recréer du lien social par
exemple veut aider aussi à
l'apprentissage des enfants je peux les
divertir aussi donner la météo au
vélodrome jeudi pose des questions et
rassure certains sont dubitatifs
d'autres curieux ici c'est une personne
qui le pilote et qui parle mais but 10
est utilisé dans d'autres cadres et à
une voix de synthèse
on a deux cas aujourd'hui qui sont
utilisés le premier cas c'est pour les
personnes âgées le deuxième cas c'est
pour les enfants malades où on commence
à déployer dans certaines écoles body ou
jeudi et sur la chaise
de la classe à la place où l'enfant doit
se trouver et l'enfant pilote veut dit
il ya donc une application qu'on appelle
la téléprésence la présence de ces
robots à saint quentin en yvelines n'est
pas un hasard
l'agglomération se veut à la pointe de
l'innovation dans le domaine du
numérique le monde accélère il faut que
des structures comme et notre choix en
tout cas à la pointe de toujours essayer
d'inventer et d'innover et bien sûr la
robotisation est un secteur du numérique
qui va exploser demain il faut qu'on
soit aussi à lies coûte et d'entraîner
aussi d'accompagner mes entendu tous les
to les prochaines et six robots est
entièrement conçu et fabriqué en france
à la vaccination qui se poursuit dans un
contexte épidémique qui reste sur un
tableau au un plateau haut dans les
yvelines avec elle deux tendances qui se
dégagent au niveau départemental des
chiffres de la contamination qui
baissent moins 141 paul taux d'incidence
nombre de nouveaux cas pour 100000
habitants recul très léger également du
taux de positivité
mais du côté des hôpitaux cela reste
très tendue rajeunissement des passions
entrants et pas d'amélioration d'ici dix
jours dit la rs les taux d'occupation de
lit en réanimation et à 140-150 4,2 pour
cent en ile de france six cent trente
cinq patients étaient hospitalisés hier
sur le territoire et dino à 49 de plus
en une semaine et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1575 personnes sont
décédées du colis 19 dans les hôpitaux
du département
dans ce contexte est l'hypothèse d'un
report des élections régionales et
départementales déjà ajourné une
première fois plane encore elles sont
prévues pour rappel les 13 et 20 juin
prochains à la surprise générale le
gouvernement a lancé une consultation
auprès des 35000 maires de france sur la
question ils devaient rendre leur avis
avant ce lundi midi
et d'après les premiers résultats les
maires se sont positionnés très
majoritairement en faveur du maintien de
ces scrutins
l assemblée nationale elle débattra
demain et le sénat mercredi des
discussions suivi d'un vote
à ce propos le député des yvelines
député modem bruno myle yens s'étonne de
la lettre adressée par l'union des
maires des yvelines aux élus c'est dans
celle ci le président de l'umih est
fière fonds aux demandes au maire de se
prononcer pour le maintien de ce scrutin
au mois de juin faute de quoi
explique-t-il un report risquerait
d'avoir des conséquences sur les
investissements du conseil régional et
du conseil départemental
pour bruno milliet nous voilà qui
ressemble à un chantage il était
l'invité de patrice carmouze dans
l'émission paf sur tv 78 j'ai reçu des
réponses qui sont plutôt en faveur du
report à près de 70% en ce qu'ils m'ont
répondu mais à peu près une cinquantaine
de maires sur les 87 de la
circonscription mais j'ai peur que ce
résultat ne soit pas le même que celui
qui va recevoir le prêt chez je
m'explique
vendredi un courrier de l'union des
maires des aînés parti chez nos amis
maires je vous cite simplement la
dernière phrase que je trouve un petit
peu extraordinaire je vous lis c'est sur
le mail je ne peux pas cacher non plus
mes craintes face à un report renouveler
et à ses conséquences sur
l'investissement public de la région et
du département et par conséquent sur la
conduite de vos projets municipaux 500 à
tout petit peu le chantage puisque dans
la led
on dit que bien évidemment l'union des
maires désignés mais plutôt pour le
maintien l'émission paf
à voir ou revoir en intégralité sur tv
78 points comme et c'est également à
retrouver à la radio sur sensation
yvelines impossible d'avoir le moindre
réseau téléphonique pour les habitants
de bullion ça sera bientôt un mauvais
souvenir la commune fait partie des
nouveaux sites 4g qui seront déployés
d'ici deux ans dans le cadre de la
convention new deal mobile signée entre
l'état les opérateurs pour réduire les
zones blanches sur le territoire le
secrétaire d'état cdh rico est venu
lyon justement pour en détailler les
contours c'était vendredi les détails à
ce sujet d'astrid bergère alain rolland
parle de la 5g certaines communes comme
bullion sont en zone blanche
mais cette faiblesse du réseau sera
bientôt une histoire ancienne vendredi 9
avril cédric au secrétaire d'état chargé
de la transition numérique a signé aux
côtés de la députée aurore bergé et du
maire de la commune
une convention pour déployer la 4g dans
le village quand vous êtes à l'intérieur
de la mairie lindor vous avez zéro barre
pour appeler ne serait-ce le 17 ou le 18
mais aussi très aimé dans certaines
zones de la commune où il ya des
activités sportives ou périscolaires
vous pouvez même pas appelé les
gendarmes
autre but you est une zone protégée et
possède des bâti traditionnel pour
implanter ses antennes il faudra
respecter le paysage maintenant il ya
des travaux très précis qui sont menées
pour qu'on les voit moins pour qu'elles
soient pas visibles pour qu'on ne les
voit pas quand elles sont à proximité
d'une église ou d'un bâtiment historique
donc on a la capacité de faire en sorte
de ne pas dégrader
l'espace environnement tout en
implantant de l'antenne la commune aux
concertations avec les services en
charge de l'installation a déjà
identifié deux sites pour implanter les
antennes un boutillon simple entrée dans
une zone boisée un peu en hauteur de
façon à pouvoir orienter l'antenne sur
le hameau qui est puis dans centre bourg
on se situe de rêve dans une zone qui
est l'ancienne station d'épuration qui
est un petit peu en recul au niveau des
habitations
au total ce sont seize pylônes qui
seront installés d'ici deux ans dans les
yvelines
l'opération est entièrement financé par
l'état c'est l'annoncé faite vendredi
par les dirigeants de cinq grands
groupes renault atos dassault systèmes s
et stmicroelectronics est à l'aise la
software république va prochainement
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
ces entreprises vont mettre en commun
leurs compétences au sein de cet
écosystème pour développer la mobilité
du futur nicolas landry il faut imaginer
la sorte de laboratoire géant voilà le
siège de la software et publics le
bâtiment odyssée construit à côté du
technocentre renault de guyancourt
il devrait accueillir à partir du mois
de septembre 2021
les premières équipes composées de
collaborateurs venant des cinq grands
groupes fondateurs
atos dassault systèmes
stmicroelectronics thales et renault là
on assurément des l'horizontale
donc au des grandes entreprises se
mettent ensemble parce que les enjeux
sur lesquels on travaille la
digitalisation la transition énergétique
c'est les thèmes qui coupent
horizontalement le secteur dans le cadre
de la software et publique ses cinq
grands fleurons français vont apporter
leurs compétences
une mutualisation des expertises dans la
mobilité les composants électroniques
l'intelligence artificielle le big data
et d'albert sécurité objectif développer
des solutions numériques et écologique
pour la mobilité de demain
je pense qu'à travers software
république on peut nous 5 et beaucoup
d'autres montrer qu'on a tout ce qu'il
faut en europe pour construire cette
mobilité intelligente il va falloir que
on accueille on attire beaucoup d'autres
membres des grands des moyens des petits
des startups du monde académique pour
vraiment faire vivre ce projet horizon
tellement on est en train de changer de
paradigme a en fait on en train de
passer d'une automobile connectés certes
mais à des systèmes hyperconnecté les
smartphones sur sur ses roues en fait
c'est un des apports qu'on se propose de
mettre sur la table c'est de cette
capacité à cyber sécuriser des systèmes
pour lequel sans prendre de te faire
devant pas de la vie des gens peut
mettre en jeu d'autres grands groupes
centres de recherche les ipm & start up
pourrait rejoindre à sauf toi république
l'objectif à terme est de proposer des
offres globales de services autour de la
mobilité aux collectivités aux
industriels et aux particuliers
toujours à guyancourt le conseil
municipal des jeunes distinguer le cmj
vient d'être lauréat du trophée eco
actions phares à missaoui que vous voyez
à l'image mère enfant elle a reçu des
mains du président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand c'était la
semaine dernière récompense pour une
action le guide du goûter un livre de
recettes pour bien manger après l'école
et distribué par les jeunes élus à tous
les élèves de guyancourt on se quitte en
musique et sur ces images retour en 2014
avec la venue de des knicks
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines le rappeur américain s'était
produit dans le cadre du festival twenty
fort aux côtés des grands noms du hip
hop comme xzibit édénique de son vrai
nom earl simmons s'est éteint vendredi à
new york à l'âge de 50 ans il avait été
hospitalisé suite à un infarctus causée
par une overdose une semaine plus tôt
plus de 30 millions d'albums vendus dans
sa carrière des tubes comme party hot xg
dang évident que yahoo ou encore who
were de partis ou r2 wared de ouerdes
good as tu sais je vais y arriver qu'il
avait interprété à 50 ans divine il ya
sept ans le journal se clôturent
d'ailleurs sur cet extrait merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
télé 78
non
du banco
la pelouse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]